I'm Jerry Brito I'm a senior research
fellow to Mercatus Center at George
Mason University and I'm also director
of its new Technology Policy program
bitcoin is a virtual currency there are
two main benefits of Bitcoin that people
who like Liberty are going to be excited
about one is this idea that a central
authority doesn't control the money
supply and so they can't just print more
money so your money is more my supplies
more stable your money is gonna retain
its value
there's no commodity backing it up it's
also no government there are other
entity backing it up there is no bitcoin
corporation there is no Bitcoin building
its peer-to-peer the same way you have
BitTorrent or Skype where all of the
computers every user sort of contributes
their computing capacity to the network
while the ledger is an everybody's
computer by joining that network you are
solving a very difficult math problem
every ten minutes one of the computers
connected to the network gets 50 Bitcoin
so in a sense is kind of like a lottery
so by by participating you get 50
bitcoins here's where I think bitcoin is
really revolutionary if the United
States wants to block money from going
to WikiLeaks where do they go well they
go to PayPal Visa MasterCard so the
world and put pressure on them there
with Bitcoin there's none of that
there's nobody in the middle to to go
after it was started a couple years ago
by somebody calls Toshi Nakamoto who is
a very talented cartographer who solved
distributing the ledger
he is very privacy conscious and we
really don't know who he is
whether bitcoin succeeds or fails itself
is really neither here nor there if it's
not Bitcoin it's going to be something
else that is going to be a virtual
currency it has distributed that's
anonymous and it doesn't have central or
intermediary that can either print money
or be shut down
you